WHERE FOUR OR MORE PEOPLE WERE
SHOT.
THE MAN WHO KILLED EIGHT PEOPLE
AND HIMSELF AT A FEDEX WAREHOUSE
IN INDIANAPOLIS LAST WEEK BOUGHT
HIS TWO RIFLES AFTER HIS FAMILY
REPORTED HIM TO POLICE AS A
MENTAL HEALTH RISK.
INDIANA IS ONE OF AT LEAST 17
STATES AND WASHINGTON, D.C.,
WITH A RED FLAG LAW ALLOWING A
JUDGE TO PROHIBIT A PERSON
FROMMFROM
Y A
BUYING A GUN.
THE SHOOTER, BRANDON HOLE, WAS
NOT ON THE STATE'S RED FLAG
LIST.
NIKKI BATTISTE IS IN
INDIANAPOLIS.
IF POLICE KNEW THAT HOLE COULD
BE A RISK, WHAT HAPPENED IN THIS
CASE?
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING.
POLICE DID VISIT THE FORMER
FEDEX EMPLOYEE LAST YEAR AND
CONFISCATED A SHOTGUN.
IT WAS NEVER RETURNED, BUT HE
NEVER ENDED UP IN THE STATE'S
RED FLAG SYSTEM WHICH MAY HAVE
PRESENTED HIM FROM BUYING A NEW
FIREARM.
JUST A FEW MONTHS LATER, HE WAS
ABLE TO LEGALLY BUY THE TWO
ASSAULT-STYLE RIFLES OFFICIALS
SAY HE USED AS MURDER WEAPONS
HERE AT FEDEX.
INVESTIGATORS SAY 19-YEAR-OLD
BRANDON HOLE WAS QUESTIONED BY
THE FBI LAST YEAR AFTER HIS MOM
TOLD POLICE HE MAY TRY TO DIE BY
SUICIDE BY COP.
>> HE WAS DETAINED FOR MENTAL
HEALTH REASONS, AND THEN HE WAS
EVALUATED BY MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
>> Reporter: DEPUTY POLICE CHIEF
CRAIG McCARTT SAID THE CASE WAS
REFERRED TO THE MARION COUNTY
PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE.
STANDARD PROTOCOL UNDER THE
STATE'S RED FLAG LAW.
>> THE PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE CAN
GO FORWARD WITH THAT PAPERWORK
AND SUBMIT IT TO THE COURTS.
THEN THE COURTS DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THAT PERSON IS A
DANGEROUS PERSON AND IS ABLE TO
POSSESS A FIREARM.
>> Reporter: THAT CASE ENDED
WITH A PROSECUTOR WHICH SOUNDS
LIKE THE RED FLAG LAW NEVER
KICKED IN.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
IT DID NOT GO BEFORE THE COURT.
>> Reporter: IT'S NOT CLEAR WHY
HOLE'S CASE NEVER MOVED FORWARD.
THE COUNTY PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE
TOLD CBS NEWS IT IS CURRENTLY
REVIEWING THOSE RECORDS.
>> THE REASON THEY CALL IT A RED
FLAG LAW IS THERE'S SOME WARNING
SIGNS THAT ARE CLEAR TO PEOPLE
WHO KNOW WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING
AT.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE IT WAS PRETTY
CLEAR.
>> Reporter: MIKE LAWLOR HELPED
CREATE THE NATION'S FIRST RED
FLAG LAW PASSED BY CONNECTICUT'S
STATE LEGISLATURE IN 1999.
HE SAYS RED FLAG LAWS NEED TO
MAKE THE INVOLVEMENT OF A JUDGE
MANDATORY TO PREVENT SHOOTINGS
LIKE THIS ONE.
>> THE INDIANA STATUTE IS
EFFECTIVE IN THE MOMENT, THEY
CAN GRAB THE GUN, BUT THERE'S NO
FOLLOWUP, NO MANDATORY FOLLOWUP.
IT'S DISCRETIONARY AND EASY FOR
THINGS TO FALL THROUGH THE
CRACKS.
>> Reporter: AS THE VICTIMS'
FAMILIES WAIT FOR ANSWERS, THEIR
LOVED ONES AVENUE' LIVES ARE BE
HONORED.
ANGVERAGE
ANGELA HUGHLEY SPOKE OUT AFTER
SHE WAS HIT IN THE PARKIN LOT
AS SHE ARRIVED FOR HER SHIFT.
>> MY SON WHO WORKS THERE, WHO'S
AN EMPLOYEE, PULLS UP, TALKING
ME THROUGH IT, MAMA, CALM DOWN,
IT WILL BE OKAY.
YOU'VE GOT THIS.
I'M NOT NO VICTIM, I'M A
SURVIVOR.
>> Reporter: AT LEAST FOUR OF
THOSE KILLED WERE MEMBERS OF THE
SIKH COMMUNITY.
THE ATTACK HAS RENEWED FEARS
AMONG AMERICAN SIKHS THAT THEY
MAY BE TARGETED FOR HATE CRIMES.
INVESTIGATORS ARE STILL TRYING
TO DETERMINE A MOTIVE INCLUDING
WHETHER HATE PLAYED